معادله المعقده وقع فيها الملياردير ايرون
ماسك بعد استحوا به على تويتر بينما
يسميها كسر قيود حريه التعبير والتغريد
وبين الاتهامات الموجهه اليه بفتح الباب
امام المعلومات المضلله وخطاب الكراهيه
الموضوع يزداد اشتعالا تارها على الشطين
وشركات واخرى مع الحكومه ودول مؤخرا كان
يناقش الموضوع مع رئيس الفرنسي مانويل
وبناء على تطورات الاخيره حذر مسؤولون
امريكيون من ضروره تجنب مزيد من العنف قد
يساهم فيه العصفور الازرق خلال الاشهر
المقبله مسترشدين بانتشار محتوى متطرف كان
دعم مشاهير لنازيه وظهور دعتنا العنصريه
مسابح في هذا التقرير
منذ استحواده على تويتر يؤكد الى الماسك
انه اشترى تويتر لانه يعتبره الساحه
الرقميه العامه للديمقراطيه وان ضبط
المحتوى امر مقيد جدا لكن رؤيته لحريه
التعبير تثير مخاوف من زياده الاساءات على
المنصه ماسكه طرفه بان انطباعات خطاب
الكراهيه ارتفعت فعلا لكنه اعتبر ان
الاعداد المذكوره للتغريدات المسيئه مضلله
مصر قال ان العصفور تحرر فرد عليه المفوض
الاوروبي للسوق الداخليه تيري بريتون ان
العصفوره الذي تحرر سيطير بحسب قواعدنا
الاوروبيه وهدده بالغرامه والاغلاق قبلها
كان ماسك اصدر عفوا واسعا عن معظم
الحسابات المحظوره منها حساب الرئيس
السابق ترامب لكن على الجانب الاخر علق
مالك وتويتر حساب المغني الشهير كانويست
لانتهاكه قانونا
التحريض على العنف وكذلك اكد انه لن يعيد
تفعيل حساب صاحب نظريه المؤامره الامريكيه
اليمني المتطرف اليكس جونس واخيرا السؤال
المطروح هو اذا كانت قرارات ماسك مرفوضه
فلماذا اذا كلما طرح استفتاء ان على صفحته
تاتي النتيجه
لصالحه غالبا
[موسيقى]
تويتر
همم
الجروب حق تويتر وخلاها عدد قليل من الناس
وقد ينجحه وقد يفشل لا سمح الله ولكن هي
في النهايه رؤيا وهي رساله اعلاميه قويه
عندك محتوى ما عندك محتوى
اجري بالمحتوى انا محتوى عندي واحد نظيف
افضل من 100 محتوى غير مجدي لا تاثير سلبي
زي ما صار في اسهم سمعنا طاحت زي ما صار
انه اي شخص يقدر ياخذ اسمك ويثق بالحساب
باسمك وهو مو انت يعني
مع الافتر كتير فحس ان انا اكتر زياده هذا
الشيء ينفرني من التطبيق اني ما هاعمل
حساب فيها ابدا يعني بعد اللي صار ممكن
موضوع انه ممكن اي احد ينتحل شخصيه اي شخص
يعني هذا موضوع مربي كله
نشيطين اكثر من اي احد ثاني فبالتالي اي
تغيير بيطلع الجميع من بدايهنا لحد اعلى
يعني القمه وحقيقي انا اجد انه التقنيه
مهم جدا الواحد اذا بيجيء همم يقدر يدخل
ويكتب حساب باسمي وينزل فيه اللي يبغاه ده
بدون اي اشتراطات بدون اي عقوبات بدون اي
ده فراح شيء
مره ما هو سليم يعني
[موسيقى]
من الكويت ينضم الينا رولاندا بناجم
مستشار في امن وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتحول الرقمي سيدرولاند اهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه كيف يتم تحديد المحتوى
المسموح وغير المسموح به في تويتر يعني هل
من معايير تحدد ذلك في نظام المنصه
صباح الخير تويتر
في اليوم يا رولاند ماسك بحجم تويتر في
اوروبا وما خلفيه اجتماع ماسك مع رئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
على قرارات تويوتا لاخر فتره او خاصه
بالمواضيع المتعلقه بايكوبيت كرونه جاءت
كورونا يلي قرروا يشيلوا كل المعايير
العلاقه اذا بدك الاخبار الزائفه متعلقه
بكرونا خاصه انه في كثير عالم كانت تقول
عن كرونه انه هذا مؤامره
كل العالم لانه ما هي الطعم او الباكسين
فهذا الموضوع وقفه لهم ما استشر مين ما
كان في يحكي بده اياه على تويتر من دون اي
ضوابط تحديدا وخاصه النجاح بعد ما انتهيت
شو عم بيصير بالسين ولاد حسابات كانت هي
متخصصه
وهو همم
الثقه بين تويتر والن فهل من خطط لمنع
الاخبار الزائفه والمطلقه
اولويه الا كيف بده يعمل مصاري تايرد
للاستثمار لدفعوا بتويتر والنقطه الثانيه
اللي هو قال انه انا ما راح استخدمو
بالسياسه بس نشوفها عم نستخدم بالسياسه
بشكل كبير كبير وتحديدا من السياسه
الامريكيه بدعم الحزب الجمهوري ضد الحسد
الديمقراطيه بالانتخابات شفناه
بالانتخابات النصفيه وهلا بموضوع
الانتخابات الامريكيه المقبله ولو بعد
بكير طيب ما علاقه ماسك
بالمنصات او الحسابات التعبير القائمه على
اساس عنصريه ودعم العنف واتطرف شهدناه
شخصيا يتواصل ويتفاعل مع نشاطاء ينصرون
العنصريه مثلا مؤخرا
يعني العن الشيطان بهمه الا حاليا الارقام
ما عم بهمه ولا نسبه التفاعل وقتها شيء
بيعمل تفاعل بالنسبه للعلوم
والراي المضاد هذا كل يوم ما شفت تغريده
لانه ماسك في نسبه التفاعل على تويتر
اليوم فهذا الشيء كلمه تحكي بموضوع شوي دي
بيت شوي في عندك اشكاليات كثير كبيره
بتزيد نسبه التفاعل يلي معه ويلي ضد فك
الملاك لهم المذيع طيب ماسكه المتعلقه
بالعنف والعنصريه هل هذا
سيزيد في تويتر هل هذا
بين الحسابات
اذا بنشوف اخر شيء عمله مصر في موضوع
تسريب بيانات متعلقه بامن الرئيس الامريكي
عنجد تسيل العنصريه بين الحسبان
في امريكا
واليوم واحد لهم مص بده ينشر بيانات جديده
متعلقه
راح نكون عم تواجهين
كثير كبيره على عدد
صحيحات الجديده التي ادخلها ماسك على
تويتر هل كانت ضروريه فعلا
ابو الهنا حسب الاولويه بالنسبه للالماس
التحديثات الي عملها الو مسخره شغل ثاني
زياده تفاعل ويقدر اذا بدك ما تدخل ثابت
لتويتر خاصه الاعلانات تبع الشركات وهذا
الموضوع